ein steig im november
nass und windig 2300 soldatinnen und
soldaten aus österreich deutschland und
kroatien stellen sich den militärischen
aufgaben sowie den harten
wetterbedingungen die übung european
advance 2009 10 ist die größte
gefechtsübung des bundesheeres in diesem
jahr und findet in ober und
niederösterreich und vor allem am
truppenübungsplatz einsteig statt
österreich stellt im zweiten halbjahr
des nächsten jahres das transport
element der europäischen logistik partei
habe den auftrag im wesentlichen zwei
bereichen wörtlich eingesetzt in einem
feldlager dieses zu planen zu errichten
zu betreiben wir produzieren hier bis zu
230.000 liter wasser selbst trinkwasser
und im zweiten wesentlichen auftrag den
wir haben es versorgungsgüter nach vorne
zu bringen
dort wo es einen triathlon bedruckbar
sozusagen wie hier in steinbach benötigt
geübt wird die zusammenarbeit bei einer
stabilisierungs operation im rahmen des
einsatzes der nato
wir üben hier gerade mit internationaler
beteiligung spricht mit soldaten aus
deutschland aber auch aus kroatien hier
eine gemeinsame übung damit diese
versorgungseinheit in dieser eu
battlegroup dementsprechend auch
vorbereitet sein kann weil nächstes jahr
im märz gibt es die internationale
zertifizierung in deutschland und auf
dahin bereiten wir uns vor und
trainieren wir hin
die eingesetzten truppen üben taktische
verfahren in einer fiktiven instabilen
krisenregion um konflikte professionell
zu lösen